regardez ce qui se passerait si on avait
plus les matières plastiques
[Musique]
incontournable plastique c'est le
matériau roi depuis les années 70 le
plastique asus offert solide plus
résistant à la chaleur que l'aluminium
on apprécie sa légèreté la france en
produit depuis les années 50 et c'est
une fierté nationale
un coude dans le périgord pour inaugurer
une nouvelle usine de stratifiés
plastique un ministre fait le
déplacement
cette usine de cause n'a rien à envier
aux installations américaines en 1960
à en croire les reportages de l'époque
la france a produit trois cent mille
tonnes de plastique
il est utilisé dans tous les domaines
monsieur qui conduit sa voiture la
ménagère qui passent l'aspirateur ou son
café l'enfant qui joue l'enfant qui rêve
aussi chacun dépend déjà de cette chimie
des grosses molécules récente mais en
plein essor des maisons 100% plastique
des voitures aussi des avions et même
des vêtements de créateurs comme paco
rabanne jamais sans doute le polystyrène
et le chlorure de vinyle ne s'était
trouvé en aussi agréable compagnie
du plastique aussi pour des emballages
des bouteilles jetables à la bouteille
dit hier qu'il fallait récupérer laver
au prix d'une manutention coûteuse
succède aujourd'hui aux aidants terre la
bouteille que l'on jette purement et
simplement purement et simplement
sauf que ces emballages ses sacs ses
bouteilles
ils terminent parfois à l'eau dans les
mers dans les océans
c'est ce que constatait déjà en 1974 le
vulcanologue sensible aux questions
écologiques haroun tazieff
vous avez en mer rouge dans le sud de la
mer rouge vous avez dû des plastique qui
flottent
récemment j'étais dans le sud de l'océan
pacifique c'était la même chose
la pollution gagne le bien le plus
précieux de l'humanité qui est l'eau
pour que le recyclage s'organise en
france il faut attendre la fin des
années soixante dix et trente ans plus
tard encore bien des déchets lui échappe
en 2016 seul un quart des emballages
plastiques été recyclés
[Musique]